dann übernahmen sluka meine liebe
freunde ich sag euch heute wieder recht
herzlich willkommen heißen zu einer
neuen episode tectoyou sei immer starten
wir heute mit dem besten tik tok der
woche
[Musik]
ja eigentlich war der take on me als
musik darunter aber youtube recht und so
nahm ich heiße aber laser luca also
könnte mir gerne folgen verbessere tik
tok auf der ganzen welt
[Musik]
noch
alltag krass danke für den live acts
mara und damit herzlich willkommen wir
heute zu also wenn main kanal jetzt noch
nicht abonniert hatte werden die waadt
sprachenlernen babbel
[Musik]
ein sorry wir jetzt schon die daumen
kommentare von leuten sagt sammer habt
ihr das nicht so gesehen die neugier ist
links vorne ist wild von ina rösing
träume metal hammer diese folge ist ist
voll mit krassen tricks heute
[Musik]
mein lieblings formatiert execution
bayerisches einfach nur das
haben wir auch qualitativ hochwertigen
content heute wie viel für die brille
normale 1000 euro war for you today i do
more diversen wahrheit das abonnierte
doch gerne meinen kanal und haben videos
kostenlos ist
diesmal so man selbst ist richtig leise
und den eltern
[Musik]
der wohl dort spielen ich finde das geil
was wir heute alle gemeinsam für tricks
und live hacks erfahren man das ist ja
hier bildungs youtube apropos bildung
allerdings meine lieben freunde neuer
übergangs meisters jetzt wieder am werk
die nächste person im nächsten tag job
videos schaut die nachrichten im
fernsehen und sieht dann das dass sein
garten ist aber seht einfach selbst
stellt euch vor ihr schaut euch diesen
nachrichtenbeitrag an mit dieser dame
und er läuft da so ein typ rein so ich
glaube diese klopapier - werden nie
aufhören hat sie gesagt
juliana abu kommentiert mal alle unter
dem video ila nabu
[Musik]
dazu habe ich eine ganz kurze frage an
euch und zwar bei mir ist es so wenn ich
etwas tipp an meiner tastatur oder auch
beispielsweise am handy ich schaue nicht
auf die buchstaben man weiß irgend also
man weiß ja wo die buchstaben sind ich
glaube jetzt nicht das ding das
irritieren wird oder was ist das video
aber der filter der filter ist so over
you ist einfach
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist das erste richtig coole kreative
ticks auf video
[Musik]
mein beileid nie so ein heimisches nach
bio von get back to bring something und
fanden die ihre high end denn dort lernt
wieder was gelernt heute im video echt
wahnsinn also ich könnte einen kanal
wirklich auf herr doktor lehrer
professor luca um nennen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
war somit das beruhigend sste video das
ich je gesehen habe
[Musik]
alles klar die handschrift von justin
bieber schon mendes und zac efron beim
einkaufen die nächste person hat seine
katze auf dem arm und sobald er anfängt
zu singen hört die katze direkt auf
wütend zu sein und so rum zu knurren und
ich mein achtet einfach auf dem weg der
katze ist unbezahlbar hat es mal so was
extrem witzig
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ja ich glaube jeder
schau mal ich selbst hatte das gerade
noch vorgestern oder irgendwie so ich
hab ne wolz aufgenommen wirklich was
richtig lustig fand genau in dem moment
und die walz gehen dann halt eine halbe
minute und dann abgebrochen und dann
musste ich meine lache hat nochmal faken
uns allen hocken so kleine schauspieler
drin
[Musik]
ja und danach frage ich mich immer warum
ich so was auf meiner homepage angezeigt
bekommen
auf diesem schild steht frei dabei fühle
ich mich gar nicht frei sowas geht halt
auch wirklich nur in amerika in
deutschland wenn du allein über geguckt
hat das hatte der schon gesagt ok einmal
rüber führerschein fahrzeugpapiere bitte
ja zu hause ja ich werde nicht mit ihr
verwandt von mir jetzt allerdings auch
schon zum vorletzten tik tok für heute
meine lieben freuen uns wieder qualität
pur
es ist
es ist ja das tik tok hat 60.000 likes
und ich frage mich wo die alle herkommen
ich gehe doch mal lernen
nein ich will keinen war zu machen aber
ich kann das hier das ist das aus von
nico ach das ist daraus vor
das ist dass das ist alles ja ich denke
genau das gleiche wie hier
ich zeige euch jetzt noch ein tick tock
video
jaja kommt schaut einfach
wie wenig hobbys haben haben einige
menschen anders habe ich das heute
wieder beende meine lieben freunde wenn
euch die heutige wie sony pictures of
you sehr gefallen hat dann lacht gern
einen daumen hoch unter dem video hier
da und wenn ihr noch keiner modernster
form einem kanal dann klickt hier auf
dem spiel denn dann werdet ihr ab und an
einem kanal ist super es ist kostenlos
und verpasst keine videos mehr und hier
ist die letzte episode tik tok tuesday
für euch noch mal verlinkt also klickt
dort gern drauf als er letzte woche
verpasst habt super qualität content
wieder phänomenal weltklasse video
klickt drauf oder kriegt da drauf oder
auf gar nichts mehr geht